43 people were shot last weekend in
chicago
three fatally continuing a long-standing
crime trend
in a city that has been continuously and
exclusively
run by democrats since 1931. the current
mayor has not done anything about it
even as shootings have spiked 50 percent
over the past year 5-0
but now the current democrat mayor
insists
she has finally identified the problem
what is it
take a guess what do you think is the
problem corruption
no no lawlessness not a chance
bad education nope do you know what the
problem is
it's it's the answer to every one of
these social issues
racism a radical racialized regime is
letting criminals off the hook
from chicago to new york indoctrinating
kids into hating their country
and even attempting to replace the
american
flag something that i called just about
three four days ago
happy juneteenth i'm michael knowles is
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from friday is from rachel
williams who points out that if we're
always
healing then we are choosing to remain
sick this is so true
people who say we need to heal we need
to you know we just need to
come out come here talk about it we need
to heal it's the same sort of people
who go to therapy for 40 years but never
solve any problem
the idea is that there's no end there's
no cure there's no victory this is what
barack obama actually told us about the
very
day of juneteenth which is so much in
the news and we'll get to it in a second
because the libs completely proved me
right about it
like within 48 hours but the idea is
there is no victory there is no win
there is no healing there is no cure
it's the perpetual revolution that never
stops it is never completed which is how
the left
has totally dominated the culture it's
how they control our words
and control our minds the subject of a
new book that is coming out tomorrow
baby this is the last chance to
pre-order
get your signed first edition copy the
last chance
at premiere collectibles you know one
great way to listen to the book
is because you can read it obviously and
you can get the kindle but you can
listen to it
with your raycon wireless earbuds a pair
of raycon wireless earbuds in your ears
can make all the difference no matter
what you are listening to
you get crisp clear powerful beats at
half the price of other premium audio
brands raycons look great
they feel even better they come in a
cool range of colors they've got
customizable gel tips
included for a customizable comfortable
in-ear fit
and they're built to go wherever you go
with quick and seamless bluetooth
pairing and a compact charging case i'm
just going to be very blunt about this
they are a superior product to the
competitors on the market okay
i know look you don't care about music
you don't maybe you care about listening
to your favorite podcast for instance
but i know what you really want us to
listen to your favorite new audio book
that's about to come out
you're going to want to do that with
raycons raycon's offering 15 off all
their products for my listeners here's
what you got to do
go to byracon.com knowles there you will
get 15
off your entire rake on order such a
good deal you're going to want to grab a
pair and a spare that's 15 off at
byraycon.com
knowles buy raycon.com knowles
racism is specifically anti-black racism
by the way because that according to the
left is the only
real racism that there is there's no
such thing as anti-white racism
anti-black racism is the cause of all
the problems in chicago
so says chicago mayor lori lightfoot
who declared on thursday that the
systemic racism
in chicago is a quote public health
crisis the city needs to divert 10
million dollars in grants from the cdc
grants that were meant to fight
coronavirus to establish quote healthy
chicago equity zones quote
at almost every point in our city's
history sadly racism
has taken a devastating toll on the
public health and well-being of our
residents of color and particularly
those who are black
chicago has a lot of problems
over the past year during coronavirus
during the lockdowns i should say
shootings and murders are up 50
50 5-0 racism right it's all
white racists going out and hunting down
poor innocent black men it's all
trump supporting white men in maga hats
yelling it's magga country on the south
side of chicago
while poor old jesse smellet just tries
to eat his subway salad right
is that what it is well it is a lot like
that in that those two alleged white
trump supporters were
giant nigerian guys who were hired by
smilet himself
if you look at the crime statistics in
chicago
what percentage of the victims are black
75 percent
okay that's pretty bad 75 percent of the
victims are black
so what 75 of the perpetrators are white
no
turns out when you look at the killers
71.3 percent are black
so almost say a little bit less so do
white people make up the rest of that no
of the victims 18.9 are hispanic
of the killers 24.6 percent are hispanic
so that's that's interesting that's kind
of making up for the other numbers
and then how about white people of the
victims 4.6
or white of the killers 3.5 percent
are white so significantly less likely
to be a killer than to be killed if you
were white in chicago
racism has nothing to do with it unless
all of these black murderers are
anti-black racists these hispanic
murderers are anti-hispanic racists
probably not
racism is as we've said before on this
show
just a stand-in for very shallow
thinking progressives for secularists
to be able to make sense of the fact of
sin
we know that sin pervades the world
original sin is not some untested theory
it is just an observable fact
we are broken we all fall short of the
glory of god we all do
bad stuff and because we all do bad
stuff there's a lot of bad stuff
in the world but we can't make sense of
that anymore so the only
evil that we can ever talk about is
racism
even though there's just no it's insane
it's insane to say
that chicago's problems are because of
racism
that 72 percent of killer 71.3 percent
of killers in chicago
are black because of what because of
secret self-hating racism doesn't make
sense it's not just chicago
what this is leading to is a very
perverse
system of injustice whereby the
imaginary problem of systemic racism the
completely
made-up contrived problem of systemic
racism
don't forget the only legal racism in
this country is against whites and
asians
in university admissions it's called
affirmative action
there are other things that come out of
that other sort of grants and other
legal issues but it all goes in that
direction
it does not go in the other direction
but because we have this bizarre
distortion of reality this misperception
we have even greater injustice so for
instance during the blm riots
of 2020 many people were caught on video
there's cameras all over the place in
the society they were caught on video
looting rioting burning things to the
ground
hurting people killing people
and now they're getting off the hook if
you were a blm looter
not if you're a conservative guy if
you're a blm looter
you get off the hook according to the
data 118 arrests were made in the bronx
during the worst of the looting in early
june you know the mostly peaceful
looting
justice for george we're going to go
steal some puma sneakers i guess nike i
don't know
118 arrests since that time
the bronx district attorney and the
courts
have dismissed most of the cases
just dismiss them you bust down some
window you go and steal some guy's
property
odds are you're going to get off the
hook 73 cases completely dismissed
18 cases remain open 19 convictions
but not 19 convictions for the crimes
they actually committed
19 convictions for lesser crimes like
trespassing
which includes no jail time
not just in the bronx in manhattan there
were 485 arrests
during the blm riots specifically on
charges of looting of those cases
or i suppose not for charge they didn't
charge them so this was arrests for
looting
222 of these cases of the 485 were
dropped just completely dropped
73 resulted in convictions again for
lesser counts
like trespassing with no jail time
another 40 cases involved juveniles they
were not
really dealt with they were sent to
family court and then 128 cases remain
open 128 of 485
even have the chance of remaining open
we need to be merciful michael there are
too many people in prison
well i don't you know if crime is sh
spiking up if
shootings are up 50 in chicago that
doesn't tell me that we have an
over-incarceration problem that tells me
we have an
under-incarceration problem tells me
criminal justice reform means
putting more of these criminals in
prison for longer periods of time
giving harsher penalties to these people
to discourage the crime
but okay let's go with what you're
saying you
hypothetical liberal you are telling me
that we
in mercy and compassion we need to let
these people
off really easily and if even if you go
in and smash things up and steal stuff
and
really invade people's space and
threaten their lives we're just going to
charge you with trespassing okay
now tell me about the capital riot
tell me because just from my vantage
what do i know what do i know
i'm looking at six months at least of
blm
terrorists burning down cities across
the country killing
many people injuring many more people
stealing people's stuff and ruining
their lives
and setting buildings on fire they
mostly get their cases dismissed and
when they do have to deal with criminal
penalties it's trespassing they don't go
to jail
now fast forward you go to the capitol
riot which went on for a few hours on
january 6th
and you get some kooky people in helmets
and horns
making a mess of nancy pelosi's desk and
jumping jumping up and down
and walking out with her lectern and
those guys are going to rot in prison
they are going to have the book thrown
at them for committing
far lesser offenses than the blm
terrorists who are completely getting
off the hook
does that seem like justice to you it
does seem like justice
to the perverse racialized radicals
who believe that there ought to be a
double standard if you are
a leftist you should face fewer
consequences for committing worse crimes
than a conservative if you are black you
should face lesser consequences for
worse
crimes than if you are white they are
telling you this
almost depends on where you are in some
cases they will tell you this explicitly
they'll say this is important to
restorative justice
that because of historical wrongs we
need a double standard
to let people off the hook
this is not just true in the criminal
justice system this is true in school
punishments
there's a school district in minnesota
i'm sure there are many school districts
in minnesota
that have like this one hired an equity
committee
to make radical leftist recommendations
for how to run the school
but this particular school district has
now
gotten a recommendation from their
equity committee that the schools
stop suspending students for any offense
no suspensions because the suspensions
allegedly make the students feel shamed
and they provide no quote restorative
benefits
it makes the students who do the
shameful things they might feel shamed
by being punished so we can't punish
them anymore
the pioneer press is reporting the saint
paul public school district's equity
committee
made the recommendations because
specifically
high numbers of black and indian
feather not dot american indian students
are getting suspended
compared to white students and i guess
hispanic students and so because of that
because black students are getting in
trouble and indian students are getting
in trouble at a higher rate
that is evidence according to these
people that
the rules are unjust and we need to let
people do whatever they want
a member of the comm of the school
community says we cannot do our jobs if
the students are home
restorative practices uh he's the quote
restorative practices coordinator
at central high school okay the
restorative practices communicator
whatever that is this
is the new world that we're living in no
punishment
crime runs rampant not just in the
streets also in our schools that's a
crystal ball think about what your
culture is going to look like
in 20 years if that's the way students
are not just living today
but how they are being raised how they
will be set up to consider justice in
the future
total dereliction of education you know
it's hard to find this stuff sometimes
on the internet because the mainstream
media doesn't want to talk about it when
you want to go on to those really
nefarious websites like dailywire.com
and find this information you're going
to want to check out expressvpn
using the internet without expressvpn is
like driving without car insurance why
would you take that risk
every time you connect to an unencrypted
network
cafes hotels airports any hacker on the
same network can gain access to your
personal data
passwords financial details etc your
data are valuable okay hackers can make
up to one thousand dollars per
person selling personal info on the dark
web expressvpn acts
as online insurance creates a secure
encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet
hackers cannot steal
your personal data super secure i would
really really recommend you you get this
right now it would take a hacker with a
super computer over a billion years
to get past expressvpn's encryption okay
fire it up it's one button it's really
simple
you don't want people to know what kind
of websites you're looking at you know
what i'm talking about
talking about dailywire.com secure your
online data today by visiting
expressvpn.com
michael expressvpn.com michael
you can get an extra three months free
expressvpn.com
michael we are living in a
radicalized racialized woke
regime and they are trying to transform
every aspect of our culture they're
trying to
change the rules of criminal justice
abolish the police defund the police
the symbol of our legal system they are
no longer standing for the flag or the
national anthem
they're they're creating new flags that
are allegedly supposed to represent us
they are not recognizing traditional
american rituals or holidays they're
inventing new ones
you know you can read about this in my
upcoming book speechless controlling
words controlling words i like now that
the producers are going to jump me
they're going to
they're going to intuit better than i
can the plugs for my book
which is coming out tomorrow i'll tell
you what if you haven't already
stop what you are doing i'm going to
give you an opportunity i don't care if
you're driving down the street
you slow down okay slow down pull over
to the to the
shoulder of the road get on your phone
just pre-order speechless right now if
you haven't done it or if you have done
it already maybe you get another copy
speechless controlling words controlling
minds available wherever you can
pre-order your books
i you know how much i hate to say i told
you so
you know it pains me it causes me great
pain
i was so right about juneteenth it
it surprised even me i knew that i was
right that juneteenth quote unquote is a
bad idea
to make a national holiday i knew that
it was just
leftist claptrap that was playing on
republicans
innocence and naivete and goodwill to
try to not be seen as racist and
terrible
and i knew i knew
that it was not what people were
presenting it as i have a piece up at
the daily wire
which you can go read one on the fuller
explanation of why juneteenth should not
be a federal holiday
but i i knew it within about 48 hours
the libs proved me right specifically
here's how here's just one way in which
the libs prove me right
when you typed in juneteenth on twitter
this weekend
there was a little emoji that popped up
right next to the hashtag
that emoji was the raised fist
the power fist it was the you know the
power it's like the communist power fist
except it was in black so it's the black
nationalist power fist
and then bizarrely the knuckles
were rainbow colors i couldn't tell i
assumed it was a
a pride rainbow or a because it's pride
month i don't it's very confusing
because as far as i can tell
black pride and black nationalist
activists are generally not the most
woke on the lgbt stuff
but i don't know they were combining all
of it i googled i said
i must be misunderstanding this i must
be overreacting
two days after telling us that
juneteenth is the most american
holiday ever it's american as apple pie
and all these republicans made really
shallow arguments
for why we need to celebrate it's the
day that the republicans freed the
democrat slaves or whatever
they're going to symbolize this event
with a communist
black nationalist symbol well yes if you
just google
raise fist black power fist whatever
wikipedia which is a left-wing outlet
says
the raised fist or the clenched fist is
a long-standing image of mixed meaning
often a symbol of political solidarity
it is a common symbol of communism
oh right that's where i've seen that
before
republicans take knives to a gunfight
i'm speaking metaphorically thank you
very much i know look if i were
a blm activist i would be speaking
literally i would be burning down the
country and threatening people's lives
and i would be applauded for it
but because i'm a conservative i need to
make clear i'm speaking metaphorically
we take knives to a gunfight
it was so clear if you pay attention to
what the left does if you pay attention
to the subtle ways
that they manipulate language and
symbols to totally transform our culture
it's a topic in my upcoming book
speechless
last day to pre-order it right now if
you pay attention to this
you knew that the arguments republicans
were making on juneteenth are just
pathetic
they were pathetic say but it's a good
holiday we need to
embrace it it's about freeing the slaves
is it if the national
holiday of juneteenth was not about
creating an alternative independence day
to the fourth of july
why did they title the bill the
juneteenth national independence day act
if juneteenth were just this natural
organic holiday that was being
celebrated in parts of texas and then
now it's at the national level why
now why did it take 150 years
for this local organic holiday to
develop to the national level
how come no one had heard of this
outside of parts of texas
until about three years ago and now all
of a sudden it's the most sacred holy
day of the year
wake up people pay attention to the way
in which
the left is manipulating you
and your emotions and most notably
language
it's the topic of my upcoming book too
man they're real trigger happy today
so as they should be it's the last day
to pre-order the book so
i pointed out correctly
that juneteenth was meant as a
replacement of the fourth of july
and this is obviously in the title of
the bill and that this was
all about reframing the history of our
country which is what the head of the
1619 project
promised us when she launched that
project in the new york times
she said this is a project that aims to
reframe american history
to make slavery the center of the whole
thing so then i was reading
an op-ed by singer macy gray
why was i doing that i don't know i
couldn't tell you but i saw the op-ed
come around
and what does the op-ed say for
juneteenth america needs a new flag
that all of us can honor
her argument which is barely literate is
that
the the american flag now is just like
the confederate flag
this is an argument that i told you all
they would make
a couple of years ago why because the
argument was the confederate flag it's
the flag of slavery
and that's why we need to ban it
basically from the amazon store and we
need to ban it from public display
and i said hold on a second if they're
saying that the confederate flag is the
flag of slavery
sure the confederacy was did secede
in large part over the question of
slavery so there's a particular
connection there
but you might just as well say that the
american flag is the flag of slavery
because the american flag flew
over a slave nation for quite a long
time right
the american flag was the flag or a
version of the american flag was the
flag
in 1770s and 80s and 90s
and all those decades before
abraham lincoln freed the slaves all
those decades before juneteenth
well now the singer macy gray is
pointing that she's saying this flag
quote no longer
represents us it no longer represents
democracy and freedom i've pointed out
with these new regulations permitting
the gay rainbow flag and the blm flag
to fly in certain american outposts the
pride flag flying
at u.s embassies i pointed out that
today for the left
the rainbow flag and the blm flag are
in their mind better representations of
our country
than the american flag the american flag
which used to be a shared symbol both
republicans and democrats
who disagreed with one another on many
things they would both salute the flag
that is no longer the case now democrats
at the very highest levels
will disrespect the flag they will kneel
down
not in prayer and supplication not in
devotion but in protest of the flag
and the flag is a symbol of the country
and it's because they're protesting the
whole country
i think that macy gray is making a lot
of sense if you buy into the blm
narrative the
1619 narrative the juneteenth national
narrative i'm not talking about the
local tradition in texas
i'm talking about what has become a
national holiday now in opposition
to the 4th of july if you buy into that
stuff then of course you need a new flag
the stars and stripes do not represent
you
and they're going to gaslight you about
this they're going to gaslight you
don lemon is already doing this at cnn
he's saying
to the critics of critical race theory
he's saying cut it out stop complaining
about this
stop having any of your own views about
about american history stop making this
all about you
you know i had somebody today saying
well you know i'm just i'm worried i
want
the telling of that history i don't want
people lecturing my kid like hey you're
white you're bad because of this and
this i said
why do you think that's what it will be
i said that's the only problem
is your perception why wouldn't want
your your kid to understand
the roots of slavery and the legacy of
slavery how it is played out for
enslaved people
as a culture throughout the years why
wouldn't you want that
you don't think that telling people that
they were beaten
and sold and lynched makes them feel bad
that's right
that's right that's exactly right that's
always happy to hear it that's their
idea of uh that's
the whole thing about what privilege is
is that you you
you people don't like to have their
pleasure
interrupted their peace interrupted and
so people think that it should be the
way that it should be because they have
been taught that
in in this country but you know
telling people having people come to the
realization especially ancestors of
slaves
that they they were enslaved and that
they were beaten and they were sold that
they weren't able to accrue well that
they weren't able to go to school they
want to
go vote you think that makes them feel
good so
the folks on the other side stop making
it about you and be
curious instead of judgmental yes stop
making it about you
stop making it about you be curious
instead of judgmental and
allow us to make all of the judgments
and not be interested in your point of
view at all and allow us to reframe
american history
you know in these crazy times you're
going to want to protect yourself
and one does not only need to be able to
go on offense one also needs to be able
to go
on defense which is why i recommend ar
500 armor
protecting yourself exercising your
second amendment right means not just
the firearm portion of it but also the
armor portion of it the defense
against bad guys all right ar 500 armor
has loadouts designed for everyone
whether you need a comfortable
concealable vest for daily use maybe you
need a plate carrier for the range maybe
you need a fully equipped setup for the
worst case scenario our friends over at
ar 500 armor
have made buying body armor easy
approachable and affordable
if you are unsure what type of armor you
need or you just need some pointers
based on your needs
they have got you covered ar500 armor
has multiple packages pre-built for
people
just like you simplifies the entire
process of purchasing armor
they've got their independence day sale
going on right now so you can have your
order
in time before the fourth of july these
sales are up to 50
off select products so get them while
they last they've got rifle rated
bundles starting as low as 99
text knolls kwles eight zero two seven
to see all their promotions and special
prices running right now use code noles
for twenty percent
off right now they've got these great
packages
specifically for dw listeners so there's
something for everyone at ar 500
armor.com
knowles text knowles to 88027 for 20
off your first order tomorrow my friends
it's been a long
journey been a long journey
speechless controlling words controlling
minds my first book with words my
second book but my first with words is
available in bookstores
tomorrow tuesday june 22nd i will be
doing a live signing at 7 30 pm eastern
6 30 pm central at dailywire.com
daily wire youtube daily wire facebook
if you want a signed copy head on over
to premierecollectables.comspeechless
before the signing and order one
you got to do it you got to do it before
the signing don't forget to type your
question at the prompter when you check
out
then tune in to my live signing and i
will try to answer your question if i
don't do not fret you will still get
your signed copy that's premiere
collectibles dot com
speech let's get your signed copy tune
in tomorrow at 7 30 p.m eastern
6 30 central dailywire.com daily or
youtube delaware facebook to watch my
live signing thank you to the
many many of you who have pre-ordered
books but by my
count there are still still some of our
listeners who have not pre-ordered yes
you go do that today
also you can now do more than just tune
in
because if you're a daily wire
all-access member you can get tickets to
be part of
candace's live studio audience here at
dw headquarters in nashville
hurry uh seating is limited tickets are
gonna go fast if you live in the
nashville area or you've been planning
to take a trip here which i strongly
recommend it's a great town
now's the time tickets are being sold
for twenty dollars each so head on over
to dailywire.com
tickets today to pick up yours we'll be
right back with a lot more
during the tweedledee tweedledum handoff
on cnn
between don lemon and chris cuomo
don lemon went off on these parents
who oppose critical race theory in
schools
and he used a very subtle trick that you
will sometimes hear
leftists activists and race hustlers use
he said did you catch it he said
what's wrong with telling people that
they were beaten and enslaved and
lynched
and harassed what's wrong with telling
people that these things happen to them
you see the problem with that is none of
the people
that are being taught critical race
theory have been lynched
or enslaved or lived under jim crow
none of them perhaps their great
grandparents or great-great or
great-great-great-great-grandparents
experience some of those things but they
do not
the conflation of the people living
today
with the circumstances of their
ancestors
that's the trick here this is
this is all part of the the juneteenth
trick of barack obama in his own words
saying juneteenth
is all about there not being a victory
it's all about all the work that we have
to do it's not a day
to celebrate achievements it's a day to
keep working harder toward
the never ending march toward progress
what don lemon is saying is if you're
black you are still enslaved
you are still being you when you were
being taught about what happened
five generations ago that
is true today for you
and so you should resent that you should
feel aggrieved because of that and you
deserve
some special privilege he uses that line
he says that's what privilege is is not
having to face these things
people don't want to have their pleasure
interrupted bs beca
actually the opposite of that is true
don lemon lives the most ridiculously
decadent privileged life relative to
just about anyone
in human history he is a guy he talks on
cnn all day and he goes out to his place
in the hamptons
and he gets a little grab-happy with
some of the bartenders allegedly at
one of those bars in the hamptons that
i've actually been to a number of times
so i believe the argument that he's
making
and or i believe the argument that the
bartender is making when he accuses don
lemon of grabbing him
people forget about that story but don
lemon did get me dude let's
we'll leave that for another time this
guy lives a luxurious
pleasurable decadent life
and yet he is choosing to interrupt that
pleasure
to feign grievance because
grievance carries social currency it
makes people feel good
gives you a jolt when you feel aggrieved
when you
when you think about revenge let's say
for uh
someone who is wrong to you it doesn't
matter what were wrong maybe they
someone you know
shot your paw out west or maybe someone
just like cut you off in traffic
when you fixate on the ways that you can
get back at them
for for wrongs whether they're
legitimate or or imagined
it actually does feel good
self-righteousness does feel
good and people do like to interrupt
their pleasure to pretend that they're
aggrieved that is how this culture of
victimhood
has developed all based on a lie but
it's the central lie of the 1619 project
and
the juneteenth national holiday and the
blm movement that
the worst possible historical
circumstances
for black people specifically but really
for any victim group of people
are the circumstances that they are
living in perpetually all the time with
no hope
of ever changing that
they're really upset on the left that
conservatives are calling out this
radical
ideology specifically critical race
theory the way that conservatives have
been finding out what's going on in the
schools
is not through any nefarious hidden
secret means
they're just filing freedom of
information act requests so they're
going they're saying okay these are
public documents on what the curricula
include and what sort of things the
teachers are saying so we're going to go
we're going to request them we're
taxpayers we're going to go see what
those documents are
oh hey look it's radical critical race
theory and
a journalist an nbc reporter
actually went on msnbc to complain
that citizens are using perfectly legal
means
to uncover facts about what's going on
in their schools she said this is you
know a reporter
whose job it is to uncover facts and
present them to people is furious
that while she and the rest of the
reporters are derelicting their duty
the parents are doing the reporter's job
themselves
it's hard for me as a reporter because i
don't want to put foils in a bad light
right freedom of information laws are
wonderful things but it is in fact a
tactic
of national and just hyper and
fast-growing local organizations to use
onerous public records requests so what
we'll see what we saw in maine is
asking for all of these records requests
of you know how much money did you spend
on anything involving race
and then that is used to sort of um
frame again
the school board as being um as paying
for
for um
crt which again is just not the case and
so that's what happened there in nevada
we saw
again this local group called
a nevada family alliance who was really
known for trying to get
um drag queen story hour stopped at the
local libraries
and now she one activist there told me
that this was the opportunity she had
been waiting for so she files these
onerous foia requests
gets them and then translates them in a
way that's just not correct
or accurate in a way to suggest that
again the school board is coming your
children and teachers are specifically
teaching kindergartners
white kindergartners that they're
somehow oppressors it's just not really
true um
you know it's just not uh really correct
um it's just not really how
condescending
is this woman's tone i think she's
saying many things that are not true at
the moment
and then she's complaining about true
things that are perfectly legitimate
but it's the tone that gets me this smug
condescending um and you know the
problem with it is it's just
uh it's not really it's just not quite
true
uh so well okay if you're going to
refute
the claims that conservatives have made
that critical race theory
and associated ideological movements
have
now been brought on into our schools all
the way down to elementary school
if you're going to refute that then
refute it because
we got the receipts there's a great
reporter on this on the right chris
ruffo
at city journal who has who has done a
huge investigative series on crt in
schools
he's shown specific examples of teachers
promoting the ideas that all white
people are racist
that white-led school systems
systemically quote
spirit murder black children that white
parents should become quote
white traders and that white teachers
are inherently guilty of
quote covert white supremacy right these
are specific examples from schools we've
got the documents here on the right
notably because of chris's efforts there
are a lot of other ones too and it's
i mean chris and a lot of people right
now are focusing on just
what crt means in schools right now but
this has been going on for a long time
through the broader critical theory
movement which is a major topic of my
upcoming book speechless controlling
words controlling minds so if you want
to see how this has infected schools
not just in the last few years but over
the past few decades
or even further back going all the way
back to the 60s and actually even
further back to the 30s you can read
that
in my upcoming book available now for
pre-order for the last day
now this woman says it's not happening
don't believe it it's totally fake it's
they're lying and they should stop
getting all of the documents that prove
that they're right
okay if they're just lying they're just
making this up why are you upset so
upset about them getting these public
documents that prove them right oh
that's why because it proves them right
speaking of
madness in our schools beyond the topic
of race got to get to the topic of sex
there is a
canadian professor who is under fire
right now
for encouraging young girls
to prostitute themselves when they are
young
as they are beginning to start their
careers naomi sayers who's an adjunct
professor at the university of ottawa
tweeted out quote unpopular opinion
the best thing young people can do early
in their careers is do hashtag sex work
on the side because your early career
prospects will be unstable unpredictable
low pay likely contract work and very
much
exploitative now
a spokesperson for this a spokesman for
this woman
is saying she was being ironic she was
making a criticism of capitalism
so she's saying don't don't believe that
this woman's actually encouraging
her students to prostitute themselves
but then later on
the same spokesman said that this is
just part of her point on the shaming
and slut-shaming and sex work so then it
seems like she is defending prostitution
and
the kids to go into it so this woman's
obviously very confused she does make a
criticism of capitalism she says
that's how capitalism works people out
here saying young people can be
exploited in sex work
literally that's capitalism lol and
quite literally that's any kind of work
any kind of work abolish capitalism
abolish actually abolish prison but
whatever
so this woman obviously has a couple
screws loose
she is a communist she is an insane
communist
but i repeat myself but
i actually want to take her point
seriously because i think she
unwittingly is revealing something
about the modern left and frankly the
modern right
she shares some critiques of modern
society
with conservatives she is saying that
some
aspects of the current economic system
are exploitative and
that in some ways by making an idol of
mammon making an
idol of of gdp making an idol of these
things
we are neglecting other important
aspects of our society and our humanity
in the name of boosting gdp a little in
the united states
we ship our manufacturing jobs overseas
we destroy communities in the united
states we sell out the american worker
that's just a fact is that because of
capitalism is that because of our
corporatist regime is it because i don't
know why you use whatever term you want
capitalism itself is a word popularized
by karl marx
but that that criticism of our current
economic system is one that i bet this
woman would share this crazy communist
and i bet traditional conservatives who
care about the american worker
would share right that is an error that
is a problem
but what this woman is suggesting when
she gets so wrong
is she's taking this materialist view of
humanity
whereby we are our bodies
we have no dignity we have no soul we
are just
meat and so for her if you're using your
body
to make widgets at the factory or you're
using your body
to be degraded by men on camera or
in a bordello or something then
it's the same thing but they're not the
same thing
when you use your body and your mind
to create something you are
maintaining your dignity when you
degrade yourself and you turn yourself
into an object
a a mere play thing for someone else's
pleasure
you are undermining your dignity
can actually consider sex itself i think
this is why they go so crazy with the
sex work
a wife and a prostitute engage in the
same act
right i think it's the same thing
why do we think one of them
is good and one of them is bad
well what this woman would probably tell
you what the left would tell you is
because of the patriarchy it's deluded
us and it's given us crazy conceptions
and actually it's the same thing and
it's an exploitation of men or whatever
okay
the reason we think that is because one
of them is happening
out of love in a stable loving place
that gives dignity to the woman
and the other is exploitative it's
really two people exploiting one another
it's the man exploiting the prostitutes
desperation and the prostitute
exploiting the man's desperation for sex
right the the man exploiting the
prostitutes
need for money and greed for money
and the prostitute exploiting the man's
addiction
to sexual pleasure and his need for
instant gratification and his his
degraded view of the world
that is a mutual exploitation a husband
and a wife in a loving marriage
will the good of the other person they
are building something there it's not a
zero-sum game where they're just like
i'm going to take this from you and
you're going to take this from me you're
you're actually procreating in that
situation you're creating
a child so they're they're physically
they look like the same act but they're
totally different acts what this woman i
suspect is saying is actually there's a
really conservative
argument here what she's saying is when
women are younger
let's say a woman in her early 20s
should engage in
sex work she's saying that because women
who are younger
are more physically attractive they
should take advantage of that
turn it to their advantage make some
money out of it i bet what the
conservative would say
is actually when a woman is younger what
she should do is get
married she is more physically
attractive
she's got more energy more energy to
raise kids whatever
and so yes they're observing the same
physical facts
but coming to totally different
political ends
this woman unfortunately she's gone
totally totally wrong in her view of
things
but we can actually learn from the left
sometimes we can learn from their weird
perceptions of the world that is
actually one of the main points of my
upcoming book speeches controlling words
controlling minds i want to take
the left seriously on these things i
want to take their thinkers
seriously you know so much
of this craziness
on race and sex and gender quote unquote
comes down to a misunderstanding
of really basic philosophical questions
this is why this this racial narrative
has become a kind of national religion
it's got religious
ceremonies it's why juneteenth is now a
national sacred feast a religious
holiday
it's why pride month is on the
liturgical calendar because we don't
understand the religious underpinnings
of society tick tock is where i get my
most important uh understanding
of the current obsession with race and
sex and gender in particular
here's a gal on tick tock explaining
what it means to be gender fluid oh
actually i'm gender fluid
oh okay wait what does gender fluid mean
again
gender fluid means my gender changes
depending on the
day or week or even depending on the
hour
it also means the pronouns i'm
comfortable with can change too
oh so how do i know what pronouns to use
for you and other gender fluid people
um we all express them differently but
personally i express them through
color-coded bracelets
pink means she her yellow means they
them
and blue means he him and if i'm
comfortable with this more than one
pronoun
i will combine them oh okay
so today's uh she day day
you got it okay um i'll keep that in
mind
okay you got it you got it do you see
this is obviously a confused gal so i'm
not going to go after her too much i
think that she is
expressing a very popular point of view
and no one gets the problem did you
catch the problem with her solution
how do i know if you're a boy or a girl
today well you can tell by my bracelet
if i'm wearing the blue bracelet it
means this one thing if i'm wearing this
other bracelet it means another thing
who decides what the bracelets mean
right now we looking at the symbols of
our bodies
we say that certain physical
characteristics
body parts things like that
represent man or woman
and then the radicals came in and said
you can't tell me that my adam's apple
and my broad shoulders and my other
appendages
represent man they actually could
represent woman i'm a woman you just
are misunderstanding the symbols of my
body
okay so how am i going to know if you're
a man or woman well i'm going to wear a
color-coded bracelet
well then how are you you can't be the
one to decide what the pink and the blue
mean it's the it's exactly the same
problem it just pushes it back
ultimately someone needs to decide what
these symbols mean
whether the symbol is words whether the
symbol is color
or whether the symbol is our body itself
you can read about
how to make sense of these things and
why the conservatives have just
completely
whiffed it on this issue in my upcoming
book speechless hitting bookstores
tomorrow this has become a national
obsession and it's very very confused
and it leads people to make hasty and
incorrect conclusions
so in fort lauderdale there was a pride
parade over the weekend
and someone actually ran someone over
accidentally ran someone over
all we ever heard was there was a car
involved
in hitting someone the fort lauderdale
mayor dean trontalis
comes out and says this is a terror
attack on gay people
it's terrible they're laying on the
ground this is clearly a terrorist act
against the lgbt community
this is disgusting this is we're fearful
of our lives we don't know what's going
on in the rest of the street it just
didn't look like he was here to
have a parade he was here to cause
trouble you could see it in his face you
could see
when they pull them up and they threw
them into the car and and
took them away you could see it in his
face you could tell he was a vicious
terrible
anti-gay supremacist i knew the minute i
saw this story i said nope
no that's not true i bet it was just an
accident
but the mayor says it was obviously a
terrorist attack this guy's obviously a
terrorist
so the guy who was driving the car
he is a member of the lgbtq
chorus that was at the parade he just
hit the wrong pedal
the guy is one of the people
involved in organizing the pride parade
itself
the the president of this gay chorus
justin knight
came out and he said this was not an
attack on the lgbt community
the guy who was driving was in our
club now of course we know that we know
that america is not not this
anti-gay anti-black whatever i mean it's
so clear you can just see it before your
very eyes you look at statistics you
look around the
messaging from corporate america you
look around the messaging from the
government in our schools
it's all discussing the evils of white
supremacy and all white people are
racist and
straight people are oppressive and
whatever all these sorts of things and
yet
they really believe it they are so
wrapped up in their own cult
the cult of victimhood and oppression
the cult of wokism
they can't see it the very language that
they're
using is controlling the way that they
understand
the world there's a great book coming
out about this very topic ted lou
a uh not the brightest bulb
in the congressional pack he's a
democrat congressman out in california
uh he is very upset right now because
a number of bishops are putting together
guidance on what to do about
allegedly catholic politicians who
scandalously
flout the church's teaching this wasn't
as big a deal
until very recently when we had a
nominally catholic president
who is scandalously openly
in disagreement with the church on
important things and is that actively
providing support to
abortion which is not just one issue
among many it's a very particular issue
so 60 catholic catholic democrats in the
u.s house of representatives
issued a statement of principles
decrying the quote
weaponization of the eucharist to
democrat lawmakers for their support of
a woman's safe and legal access to
abortion they're saying it's
contradictory
in the catholic church for those of you
who don't know you are not permitted to
receive the eucharist if you were in a
state of
mortal sin and if you're in a state of
mortals it's that you've committed the
sin you haven't confessed it you haven't
repented
so the the democrat politicians who are
supporting abortion
are committing the not just that sin but
they're also committing the sin of
scandal by confusing the faithful
so ted lou writes quote dear usccb i'm
catholic and i support contraception a
woman's right to choose treatments for
infertility the right for people to get
a divorce the right of same-sex marriage
next time i go to church
i dare you to deny me communion i dare
outrageous
outrageous chris hahn actually who's a
democrat that is employed by fox news
actually beat out ted lou for the
dumbest tweet on this matter he said
quote
time for pope francis to have a come to
jesus moment with catholic bishops who
deny
president biden communion their
statement is political not religious
what there's so many things wrong with
this first of all
very scandalous for a catholic to demand
that he eat his own damnation
if you eat the body of christ without in
in
an unworthy state this just according to
saint paul you are eating your own damn
nation so that when the priests withhold
it from you it's for your own good
it's so that you don't further imperil
your soul
but moreover chris hahn says that the
church needs to only act religiously not
politically
as if there's not an overlap i don't
know if chris knows this
the pope has his own country do you know
that that's
the the pope is a political figure as
well as a religious figure in
all political conflict as cardinal
manning tells us is ultimately
religious this is obviously true our our
current state established church our
woke regime
is the regime of radical racial theories
radical gender theories
this these these very very perverse
views of human nature
itself and these are being enshrined and
if you contradict that orthodoxy you
will be persecuted for it
but unlike other religious persecutions
in history this
regime is not even willing to
acknowledge
those religious foundations makes it all
the more dangerous i'm michael knowles
it's the michael knowles show
speechless i'll see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show as our institutions of
power move ever more toward critical
race theory americans are fighting back
and winning that's today on the ben
shapiro show give it a listen
you